[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALI AFSHAR: Hi everyone.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name's Ali, and today I'm
going to be taking some
questions about the
Google Drive SDK.
I'm going to be talking a
bit about the answers.
And during this process,
if you have any burning
questions, please feel free to
ask it on the YouTube comments
or on the Google+ Event and
someone will tell me, and
we'll try to get that answered
live on air for you.
So for those of you don't know,
we use Stack Overflow
for question and
answer support.
We'll really happy with that.
At the moment it seems the
community is growing and there
are a number of contributors who
don't work at Google who
are actually helping other
newer users on how to
use the Drive SDK.
So we're very happy about
that, and thank you to
everyone who is answering.
That's great that you are
part of the community.
And that's really our intention
with using Stack
Overflow is to be part of the
broader programming community.
So that's absolutely great.
So let's get started.
First question, is the only way
to download a file through
Google drive through the
download URL that is provided?
I have the file ID and would
like to make one simple call
to download the file.
Right now it looks like you have
to make one call to fetch
the file's metadata and one to
actually download the file.
Is there any other way?
Well this is absolutely right.
The correct way of doing it is
to fetch the metadata, to get
the download URL, and
then download it.
That's always going to
be two requests.
Now this is for a couple
of reasons.
The first one is the download
URL doesn't
last for very long.
This is a measure to make sure
that people just can't keep
these immortal download URIs
around for a long time because
that's not exactly great.
So we generate them, we give
it to you, and then you can
use over a short
space of time.
That's the first part.
The second part is although
the scheme for these URLs
seems predictable and you
could probably go about
generating it yourself,
we strongly recommend
you don't do that.
So for these two things,
we really
recommend making two requests.
If you're downloading that many
files that it makes a
huge difference to make a small
GET request beforehand,
I'd be really interested
to know your use case.
So get in touch with us if
that really is doing huge
network bandwidth that you
just don't want to do.
Let us know and we'll have
a look at that use case.
But for now, this is
the way to do it.
There are other ways
of downloading
files from Google Drive.
If you want to let the user
download it in their browser,
we have this web content link.
That uses a different
off mechanism and
that may be more suitable.
If you don't want to download a
file and then give it to the
user to download, they can
download it directly and you
will never have to get
involved with that.
So that's great.
You'll only find the URL with
the GET request and then the
user can download the file.
That's another option for you.
So that's that question answered
by [? CloudEar, ?]
says pretty much
the same thing.
All right, next question is
about our date and time format
in the Google Drive API.
I'm having an issue with the
create date, modify date for
the Google Drive API.
When I get the data, the time is
displayed as, and there's a
time stamp there, and they want
to know how to convert it
to and from this format.
That time format we use is RFC
3339, which is not that well
supported by some programming
languages.
PHP doesn't have a good built-in
standard library
thing to do it.
The Python standard library also
doesn't do this without a
tiny bit of tweaking.
And it's mostly because, well,
I'll use Python as an example.
Python's time zone segment on
the end of the time stamp is
actually comes with
a complete part.
So if it's seven hours before
Greenwich mean time before
UTC, it will say minus
seven zero zero.
And the format this expects is
minus seven colon zero zero.
So although this is a RFC time
stamp, and it is a good one,
and it's a consistent one.
And it is what we've been using
for a long time and
[INAUDIBLE] and everything.
So you might have to write
yourself a little function to
convert that.
I put an example on there in
Python and someone else has
put an example in PHP.
And if you look up RFC 3339, you
will find a sample in your
programming language.
So it's annoying to have to
work around, but I'm sure
someone's already done
that for you.
So that's times and dates.
And we use the same format for
all our fields that have a
time or date in them.
Great, service account.
So the question is, Google Drive
changing permissions by
service account.
They're looking for the best
approach for administrators of
Google Apps domains to modify
the permissions of a Google
Drive object owned
by other users.
OK, this used to be done by
2-legged OAuth, if anyone has
used 2-legged OAuth.
We're now moving away from
that and we've moved to a
model that is based on
service accounts.
Now we have two different types
of service accounts.
One of them is owned by a
developer console project and
the other one is owned by
a Google Apps domain.
Now this question is
specifically asking about a
Google Apps domain.
So if you go to your C panel
and you enable the Drive
scope, you can get your service
account certificate
and you can actually use that to
log in for any of the users
on your domain, to authorize
for any of the
users on your domain.
And then really you can perform
actions for that user
as if you were authorized
as them.
This is pretty useful, and it
pretty much covers the use
case in this question.
So you would authorize the user
who wants to be able to
share the files with
other people, OK?
And then you just add the
permissions using the
permissions.insert method to add
the permission for whoever
else to read or write or
comment, or even you can use
this to change the
owner of a file.
So that's that part.
There's a slight mention
of Google App
Engine Service Accounts.
So Google App Engine Service
Accounts is unfortunately yet
another way of doing
service accounts.
Now how the application proves
that it is who it is is App
Engine has its own specific
service called App Identity.
So App Identity says hi, I am
this application, so please
authorize me as a service
account for this application.
Unfortunately, that's currently
not supported
in the drive API.
We're really working hard to
support this and if I had to
guess I'd say days or weeks
this will be working.
So that's absolutely
brilliant.
It's really useful in Python
because the Python App Engine
SDK doesn't actually have enough
cryptography to do
regular service accounts yet.
Again, that's something
that's coming.
So for now, you can use these
App Engine App Identity.
One proviso is that with App
Identity, you will not be able
to use the drive.file scope.
Now the drive.file scope does
depend very much on who the
app is so that users can
authorize files for certain
applications.
And applications can't read all
the files in your drive,
just the specific ones.
So those features get
turned off for App
Identity Service Accounts.
But again, that's not exactly
a problem because with App
Identity Service Accounts, the
files are owned by the
application itself, so the
file scope is reasonable
depending on your use case.
So that's enough about
service accounts.
Just to let you know, we've
covered these two cases, Def
Console Service Accounts and
Domain Service Accounts.
And we've created two new
tutorials on using them, so
please check them out.
They're at
developers.google.com/drive.
They'll called Service
Accounts and User
Impersonation.
This is one of the things
we really want to
get absolutely right.
We do appreciate this use case
that used to be covered well
by 2-legged OAuth.
So if you have any problems,
let us know.
We want this to be
absolutely right.
OK, next question.
Google Drive changes
list API, detecting
changes at a folder level.
OK, this is a question we
get asked quite a lot.
The changes feed, to give you a
little summary, is if you're
authorized as a user you can
get a list of, more like a
timeline, really, of all the
changes that have happened to
files in their Google Drive.
So it will show this file is
modified, this file is
created, a certain
file was deleted.
And it goes in reverse
chronological order.
Each one of these changes has
a unique ID that you can
remember so you can say
I only want changes
since that unique ID.
This is the changes feed.
Really, really useful to prevent
having to download a
whole user's Google Drive, find
out what's changed, and
then modify it locally.
I'm thinking of use cases like
synchronizing applications
that you write.
So the question here
is can we detect
changes at a folder level?
Brilliant use case and
I can see why.
Unfortunately, we don't
support that.
We believe that currently the
changes feed is small enough,
there are only going to be a
few hundred maybe at most
changes, is small enough that
you can get the whole feed and
filter it for the ones that you
want in the right folder.
So each of the entries in the
changes feed will have--
as long as it's not a delete--
will have a parent
ID, for example.
And if you look at the parent
ID, you can find out which
folder it lives in.
Now I appreciate that the delete
case doesn't actually
work because we believe
very strongly that
users own the data.
So if they've deleted a file,
you shouldn't really be able
to find out what the parents
for that file were.
You shouldn't be able to
know what the title
for that file was.
The user has deleted
it and that's gone.
We do give you the file ID, but
of course if you haven't
got a mapping of file IDs to
parents, you don't know where
that exists.
So I appreciate this use case is
not completely covered, but
there's not really
much we can do.
We have to respect the user's
privacy and the fact that the
user owns the data here.
I think that's a reasonable
choice.
I'm a developer myself, so I
would like it the other way,
but I do respect the
user's choice here.
So another question asking
about 2-legged OAuth for
Google Drive from Android.
So that's a really interesting
question.
It doesn't actually work for
a number of reasons.
One, we don't officially support
2-legged OAuth on
Google Drive.
And two, I'm not sure how
you could use that
exactly from Android.
I guess you could use
it as an installed
application on Android.
So I'm not sure what the
use case is here.
Again, Mr. or Mrs.
[? Gautome, ?]
I would be really pleased to
hear your use case because
that sounds kind
of interesting.
You can use a service account
from Android.
The other thing you can actually
do which, may or may
not be suitable for you but it
would cover the use case, is
that if you have offline access,
if you have an access
token and a refresh token, you
can essentially keep them
forever and use them.
Now I'm assuming this app is
not something you want to
publish widely because if you
publish a 2-legged OAuth token
widely, and that's a permanent
token, anyone can use that.
So really you've given away
your whole credentials.
So I'm guessing this
is an internal app.
And if it is an internal app,
you can use a saved standard
OAuth2 token, or a saved service
account OAuth2 token
that has offline access.
And that can be refreshed
forever.
So I'm guessing this is for
internal use case for someone
rather than the external app.
If it is an external app, please
do not put raw tokens
in your APK, or in fact in
anything, even if it's
compiled or fiscated.
The stuff is reasonably
straightforward to reverse engineer.
So yeah, please don't do that.
Fingers crossed that is an
internal use case here.
So, done a few there.
Should we check if there
any other questions?
I'm going to check quickly if
there are any other questions
from people.
Nope, not there.
OK, so they'll let us
know if there is.
Great, so next question.
Google Drive SDK
image metadata.
Recently we launched the feature
to add EXIF data.
If you don't know what EXIF data
is for images, when your
camera, your flashy camera takes
a photograph, it stores
some information in there.
Even the cameras on
phones do this.
So the camera make, the camera
model, the aperture, the
exposure, the focal length.
These kind of things are all
stored in the image as some
extra metadata so the other
applications can look at them.
Photo applications, photo
organizing, photo editing.
We recently, last week, exposed
this data because we
index it for Google Drive.
It's very useful, lots of
photos in Google Drive.
Perfect use case if you're a
photographer, store your
photos there.
And they never will be lost.
This question is asking
for some missing
features, missing fields.
So actually, focal distance
is one that we're missing.
Focal distance, metering
mode, sensor type.
And there are some
IPTC metadata
keywords that are missing.
A perfect example, thank you
for bringing this up.
I hope this person's writing an
awesome file image gallery
application for Drive because if
they are, I really want to
use it myself because I've
got lots of photos there.
So they're just asking
for this extra data.
And there's a perfect use
of Stack Overflow.
Thank you for telling us this.
We're looking to get these
features added as soon as
possible so your
apps can work.
OK, yes, please, someone write
a photo editing app.
A photo management gallery app,
I'm desperate to use it.
OK, let's do one
more, shall we?
MALE SPEAKER: We do have
a question on YouTube.
ALI AFSHAR: Oh, do we?
MALE SPEAKER: One of them says
is there way to get files from
the Google Drive and read
it in using Java?
ALI AFSHAR: Yes.
The answer is absolutely yes.
When you say get files, I guess
you mean download files
or upload files?
Downloading files.
OK, great.
So yes, absolutely.
If you go to a URL that I will
put in the YouTube comment,
I'll tell you what it is
in the YouTube comment.
But we have a Java snippet
for doing exactly that.
You should be able to take the
snippet, copy it, paste it
into your application, and
everything should work.
OK, it's two steps.
One, you get the download URL,
and then you perform a
download using the raw
underlying HTTP library with
the added authorization
header.
But we show you how to do
that, copy and paste it.
Java is not special.
We also have identical sample
for Python, Go, PHP,
JavaScript, Ruby, .net.
And any language you want there,
please let us know.
We'll look to see they add it.
So yes, absolutely.
We love Java developers, you're
very important to us.
MALE SPEAKER: So there is
another question via Google+
Events asking about 2LOA scope
for the Drive API.
They are wondering if we can
expect a 2LOA scope for the
Drive API so they can write
apps, Marketplace apps that
take advantage of it.
ALI AFSHAR: So this
is an unsupported
feature at the moment.
But actually 2LO scoped tokens
for Google Documents List API
do currently work against
the Drive API.
So I'm not exactly overly
enamored with that because
we're trying to deprecate
OAuth1.
Well, we have deprecated it, but
we're trying to get rid of
all the use cases.
Now we specifically allowed
this for the case where
someone already has a token for
the Documents List API,
they want to start using the
Drive API, and they don't want
users to reauthorized.
We wanted to smooth that user
experience for your apps.
So right now you can get the
Documents List API scope token
from your C panel used
with 2-legged OAuth
with the Drive API.
Unsupported, may go away.
But if that covers your use case
for now, please use it.
Please look to using regular
service accounts.
I think you can even though
you are in the Apps
Marketplace, but I
think you can.
But we don't want to make it
harder for you right now to
migrate across.
So first, I'd say migrate using
the token and then we'll
look at fixing that.
MALE SPEAKER: And there's one
more question from Joshua
Owen, who says he's developing
a Hangout App that makes use
of the Google Drive Integration
via picker object
to obtain the file ID.
He says he can temporarily
share images he owns to
Hangout participants using
permission methods, but this
obviously won't work for things
that are shared to him.
Is the best way to accomplish
this to copy the file to the
local user drive and then
share out to the Hangout
participants?
ALI AFSHAR: Yes.
So if you don't have enough
authority to add permissions
to the user, or if you really
don't want to do that, it is
potentially not polite if
someone shares something with
you and then you share on, yes,
copying it to your own
drive and then sharing
it out from there
kind of makes sense.
But that's the best
way to do it.
You can, if you have permission
to add other, I
think it's called the Writers
Can Invite field, so if you
have that one set, then you can
still invite other people
to do that.
But otherwise yes, copying
it is the best way.
But that's a cool app.
I'd love to know about that.
When you launch, please let us
know because, well obviously
we're always into integrations
between two different Google
products, but I think the
collaborative nature of
Hangouts and the collaborative
nature of the drive editors,
there's really a lot of
integration points there.
So please let us know, we're
really keen to see that.
Any more questions?
No?
OK, brilliant.
Thank you very much
for tuning in.
Please keep asking your
questions and please telling
us how we can improve.
That's really useful for us.
Thank you very much,
my name is Ali.
Take care.
Bye, bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]